[Music]
hi i'm kishibashi and i'm toby i hope
you like our music
kay and i love to play music we had a
chance to write music for stillwater
this wonderful show that's so much fun
it allows me and toby you know the
composers to really to have fun with the
music and we really would hope that you
would place them with us today would
that be okay
would you like to try
uh okay we brought our instruments
got mine did you guys bring yours do you
guys have your bowls and spoons
toby what do you think are they ready
let me see
yeah they i don't know oh yeah yeah they
got them okay but let's make music
together toby you ready i'm ready okay
well let's start with the beet okay so
you guys grab your bowl and spoon
and tap along and it's okay if you don't
have one you can also just clap like me
okay
so clap along because i'm gonna start
playing the violin ready great job
everybody one two three four
[Music]
oh that was fun awesome great job wow
you guys did amazing you guys are all
musicians here now i have a question how
did that make you feel um happy
calm
excited
sad
music can make us feel lots of things
the type of music that i really enjoy
sometimes is music that just invites you
to feel it just is this open invitation
to experience something i was about
seven years old when i started the
violin and i think i love it so much
because it's like singing
it's like
[Music]
it's kind of like uh it was really
beautiful to me so i've played it ever
since kaye and i actually went to school
together so we were growing up playing
music together playing music with your
friend is probably one of the best
things you could ever do there's like
one thing better than making music is
making music with your friends and
that's so much fun hey toby why don't we
play a game sure what do you what are
you thinking
let's try and name a feeling and then
make music to match it
interesting okay let's give it a try all
right well let's start with the feeling
of happiness you ready i'm ready let's
do it
you know toby why don't you kick it off
one two three four
[Music]
i'm pretty happy that melody really made
me happy tell me what makes you happy
about that yeah the melody made me happy
and um the ukulele always makes me happy
i like the ukulele makes me happy too
ukulele's such a cute little cute little
instrument i love it
should we try the opposite sadness
let's do it
all right okay sadness here we go
[Music]
you guys hear the difference
quite different from happiness it's a
little bit slower
and there's some sad chords in there too
right
yeah absolutely you know sometimes it's
totally fine to be sad it's just that's
what we do as human beings if we have we
don't have sadness how do we know we're
happy right every feeling you have
is just as important as the other so
it's okay to feel
any of those feelings i've got an idea
for the next one how about excitement i
need some excitement good idea let's do
it
[Music]
that was pretty exciting
that's that's how excitement should feel
sometimes excitement is hard because uh
it's really fast
so you have to kind of keep up with the
music so you're kind of running along
with it that's a big that's a big
challenge for me i almost dropped my
instrument sometimes by excitement i
have dropped my instrument sometimes
from excitement so that's that's the
danger of being too excited about
playing
so for our last one how about if we try
calmness okay that'd be a good one yeah
i need to
calm down here
[Music]
[Music]
that was a lot of fun
i i felt really calm what about the
music made you feel calm it was like
long and soft
nothing changed very quickly it was very
slow and smooth yeah it took its time
and there wasn't a big beat
and uh it kind of flowed uh
do you hear that sound is that you toby
it's not me
i wonder where it's coming from maybe
you guys should go take a look yeah go
check it out let's see what that is
thank you guys so much for joining us
this is great we had a lot of fun bye